she has everything on tape chin has
everything I do but you'll never get
anywhere out for now until chill ray yes
Matt you know I just can't let some
stuff go if you want God
yeah there's no way Jose Trail
it's good you know hey no it's okay from
New York right you know I uh I always
think of Jesus so I'm always like his
sous is how you say it and I'm you know
it's good guy Friday we're a couple good
guys with Jesus mouth we have an eye I
wore beanie
yes in my ward again that word again
because I you you're the original
beating oh yeah well I'm trying to cover
up my my immaculate hairline look at
this yeah yes barbarous rogue he's a guy
he's a guy I told him before this Tiger
I've never heard one bad thing about him
nothing but good things the nice guy in
the game including his comedy nicest guy
I mean especially by me I'm still fairly
new Tommy for five years now but when I
started hey suits were on the road to me
yeah Oh Brennan and yeah there's some
good shows man you got a special man
yeah I was special you would crush and I
would eat dick no you would do by the
way only Brennan after doing Santa for
10 minutes brings like [ __ ] had
been on the road for eight years
to open for him not a lot of guys who'd
do that but it's just a testament to him
and his hard work man it's like you know
he knew where he wasn't counting he was
still bringing out guys but look to be
honest you were doing just fine after me
thank ya question it's like I I'm
thinking of a casino gig that we did he
went up there [ __ ] question yeah cool
stood up but here's the real last night
I texted him I texted this is a this is
a big deal and this sounds like I've
been doing this too long to not talk
about because that's seven years so my
girl my girl was talking to people and
we were talking they were talking about
Houston and um and and my friend said
Frank said how did how did Brendan do
and she goes she goes well he was only
on for 20 minutes but he was great it
was a great 20 minutes and she just said
it to him not not I was talking oh and I
went I went I said did you just say it
was a great 20 minutes because yeah yeah
killed and I went that's such a
milestone it's so hard to have a great
20 minutes yeah it's so it how many
people do you know how long does it take
and when somebody says that in an
offhand manner and I texted him I said
hey Congrats that's a [ __ ] and I
watched it I mean I said to his brother
I go he's he's [ __ ] he is such a real
comic now he's [ __ ] killing it and his
probably 25 minutes you know and and I'm
out tonight yeah now I did write it all
for him people think that O'Brien and
Rogan just write the job cuz you're
gonna write about my mic's actually
Emily in my kid yeah actually if
anything I would always try to give him
notes and I would write and he would he
would he go you can't do that I can't
yeah yeah I can I got to figure it out
he would even want tags because it was
too much for him yeah cuz he was like
that then now it's you and it's gotta be
me yeah is I can also seeing you at the
store you know you never shied away from
any any shows that you would show up and
whether it's a belly room show main room
like whatever like you show up and it
was is is is dope to see the the hard
work but going back to what you said
it's like the milestones that we kind of
hit along the way and I haven't been
doing as long as you it's like you know
but like the feeling you get when you're
like hey I have a three minutes I have a
five minute about ten minute get out of
it 20 minute hey I might start featuring
now on the road when you first do an
hour
holy-moly I remember bombing every step
of the way like whenever I got
introduced to a new amount of time I
could never finish it when I was ahead
it's like I gassed out even three
minutes so when I show up at the store
I'm doing open mic I was gassing out
before I got the light and we were doing
three minutes set right and then now I'm
hosted and I'm doing 15 minutes I would
gas out before 15 now I'm featuring and
you got to do about 20 minutes I'm
gassing out at 16 and a half whoa yeah
and the same thing happened when I first
started headlining I remember this I
remember this very vividly in Irvine
Irvine improv I'm doing a one-nighter
I'm feeling good I'm gonna do an hour I
have some some agents that show to help
you know managers they're homies friends
and family and I show up you know
cracking knuckles just you know you know
let's do this right and I tell the sound
guy I said hey like me at 15 like me at
30 light me out 45 and
leave the light on in an hour cuz I'm
coming off right away so I'm here I'm
doing my thing I get the first 15 I said
nice second 15 let's do this right and
I'm going and then I get the the third
so I'm at the 45 right and I said oh
this is a home run and I'm killing then
you started here the cartoon though I
mean it's going down it's going down I'm
sweating I'm I'm so what do you do for a
living I'm doing every talk I got the
worst and and then I'm like um III
literally my mind is blank right and I
go behind I go behind the curtain
I literally leave the stage and I go
grab my set list right and my homey
lookk Schwartz is hosting and he's like
what are you doing back here I'm like
where's my setlist it's right here I'm
like [ __ ] I'm I'm blanking now he's like
no you hit everything I was following
along oh you're kidding
so I grab and I go out this is like 20
seconds too long you know it's like me
the historians quick I go back out there
and I have a listen like and I'm looking
at a paper shaking I'm like only child
did that yeah
buhbuh buhbuh buhbuh and then I'm like
that's it IIIi hit everything just power
through it thank you guys that's time I
ran into rad time I ran at a time after
the 45 minute mark so I probably was a
hostage there like 50 minutes are you
are you finding that this this is these
events in this insanity is it gonna
color now cuz for me I can't help but
start writing now and some of the stuff
I was writing before with the shutdown
before the protest doesn't matter
doesn't matter so I got to start writing
about what it's like in this environment
for someone like myself who's not
doesn't need to be
what's my people aren't really
interested in hearing what I got to say
so I got to make it funny I had to
figure it out mm-hmm so it's been an
interesting thing is it what do you are
you dealing with that at all yeah III
think with with comedy I like I always
tried to talk about what I'm going
through or like what's like real to me
and you know I've been in quarantine for
months you know are you still single no
I have a girlfriend now yeah I need a
girl for a while now really yeah
it's fairly recent but you know I had a
girlfriend for a while then we broke up
I remember because when you were on the
road together yet a girl yeah and then I
didn't after that yeah that's how it
works I was like all right that checks
out descriptive it's good guy Friday so
let me know about hey Susan got Fridays
he likes the thicker girls oh yeah curvy
girls all days I remember he was mad my
homie was mad his girl got a gym
membership
no yeah no girl skinny I said this to
Brendan I said Brendan my homie asked me
he's like what kind of guy are you right
he's are you a ass man or your tip man
what kind of guy are you I'm like if I'm
being honest man yeah I'm like I'm a
slow metabolism kind of guy like the
slower the better man and I'm being so
real you will never find a realer
statement like slower habilis slow
metabolism do you like how you like my
friend is like my friend we were looking
at two girls and he goes tan look at her
and I go I know the [ __ ] and he goes on
he goes in that skirt and I go jeez dude
I go you like they didn't like thick he
didn't like curvy girls he like fat
girls he liked big curvy you know we
call him curving curvy fat son oh no no
well how big how big are the curves you
know sometimes you like t th IC ke thick
yeah I like thi cc no no so so that but
they're the god bless men like you
god bless women like that god bless the
difference I mean because we all need
love it things I D he's getting filled
with right now his speeder movies like
God bless
afraid of it I'm not afraid I'm not
afraid of curves and I'm not afraid of
thick and I'm not going to just lighten
the ass for it I but I I am I step up to
the plate yeah and and you guys know if
you like I like I like girls with
muscles huge dicks I don't care beards
it doesn't matter as long as as long as
handsome women they make fun of me
because I like a strong athletic woman
but I see big legs and a big booty then
then gets me yeah they're just something
really cool about it and I was talking
to was I talking to and started laughing
it and I found something out about
myself right so when I found out what
Santino we were talking about cartoons
in you know growing up or whatever right
and there was a cartoon called eek the
cat do you guys remember this I'd have
to see it bring the cat so it's a purple
cat and it was described like the cat
was a underdog you know it's a purple
cat with an underdog but his girlfriend
he's whoa hey hold on look yep that pink
one his girlfriend was this tall big
super curvy cat and they you know they
bring up the fact that that she was big
and he's like you think so quite was
like for gentlemen's that where you're
at so yes I think I resonated with this
cartoon so much because it was an
underdog that's it - episode 7 Watchers
listen no subway keep saying curvy and
it's triggered me because that's there's
a difference between curvy okay let's
break it down here would give us an
example an actress who you think is like
what what is what is Oh curvy look
they're all curvy to me so you had no
problem Liz oh this is great
pull up Liz oh please hurt her I G she
is pretty huh that's what I'm talking
about right there you got you're not
afraid of the house my leg real quick
you're not afraid of that I think she's
stunning bro
god I love you god bless love dude I'm
not being real glasses are those I'm the
old guy and I listen to some of her
songs she's talented as [ __ ] no hey no
one's not saying she gets sick she's not
the songbird of her generation I love
that there are men like Zeus who are not
afraid of that and who find that there's
a fish on ax men who aren't afraid of
that no I'm not afraid of it but I'm
gonna call her thick hilarious who's it
like a stunning just all-around great
grow - is Ashley Graham I think she's
great ass Ashley Graham she's so you
know super pretty
oh she's friend nxe as hell she's yeah I
think she was she just sat on the left
see I would say she's more - fast
delicious yeah she's delicious yeah it's
a woman yeah yeah it's so if you go on
my Instagram I I followed three things I
follow MMA all things MMA oh wow artists
love it and only plus-size mom oh damn
yeah yeah go to his Instagram right now
because I love it I say if you're not
into a bike we can pull it up right now
on my thing are you're just gonna see
curvy women good for you yeah if you
don't like dudes bikes and [ __ ] dicks
then go to where you're following yeah
yeah just gonna follow just oh they're
gonna come yeah yeah first one see let's
let's get into it
she's been oh girl scrolling good are
you gonna do she's such a [ __ ] come on
man she's curvy done Wow she's super bad
but I think so so there's a like there's
a second side to this I think it's also
cool because it's like you know a woman
like that can show a young girl that
there's not just one body time whatever
you are you can embrace that and I think
that's cool and you'll find love and
you'll find a man and you also find
diabetes now now we shouldn't either
honest what sometimes that's not the
healthiest she looks pretty healthy no
she's so Mike Applebee yeah but lizard
cholesterol it could be a little high
that one
the last person she's look at that right
here yes that right there that yeah I'm
all with it Doug curve her in a moment
right now no not the girl in the moment
no she's bad she's hot almost all who
you have a little bit you need a little
bit bit tighten up that's on say oh yeah
for you that's all and I appreciate you
playing ball right now but I have to
check you a little bit now you're right
cuz hey you know what intermittent
fasting wouldn't kill it and that's
that's good
that's the thing now now I'm a fan of
that I know you are the biggest thing in
the pool I know and she's got a
beautiful finger faces you know what has
just cuz you know what I follow to is
the fashion over curve yeah they got all
the Plus Size Mars that let me see that
oh fashion over novo curve that's renova
has the baddest girl if that mama curve
now we're talking it's fashion of
applies kind of girl that's not in
fashion fashion she's hot as [ __ ] I'll
give you that well I mean you know it is
what it is curvy girls man fashion of a
curve is it what to ends fashion no
there we go yes you know it is fashion
no hmm yeah alright uh-huh that's those
all right I mean they don't miss over
here's what I'm saying man loot album
you can live like everything's a hit you
can listen to it from start to finish
everything they pose hits you just love
that's how I am on the CrossFit page
grow up curls
bro ever come on Athena mother that's
just cool your all if you're about that
thing you don't mind the Fupa the front
yeah no baby girl you like I like a
curvy girl yeah and baby girl
see that's not curvy this one oh now
she's hot huh well no cuz breast you
soon be free so Brendan like no no no
she's perfect yeah yeah she's pretty hot
but you is your girl now hey soos RV
yeah she's a
girl yeah white girl no latina oh hell
yeah
Mexican actually you're an
equal-opportunity employer
equal-opportunity but you know it's like
hey hey man is it's like I don't know
that was hot that's great
see that's is they don't miss I'm
telling you they got man they don't miss
you're right I want to go to corporate
take a tour of their of their facility
over there you should to be just did you
just to inspect things yeah yeah Dora
this mallanna calf right I go back up
see right here right there right where
your mouse is no that one she's she was
in a bunch of stuff and she's stunning a
to be R majors that is their name oh
really yeah hey hey scroll down here to
uh
beautiful girl what about now go the one
in the underwear in the Rose that's sexy
to me actually I can ivy I think you got
me of course I think it's hot bro oh yes
that's that's time that's light I'm too
lightly ass for that and that's but I
understand you know I 250 pounds I'm too
light in yes that's right but not it's
just not anxious because he's got Holy
Ghost power
well no yeah it's it's all about your
mindset and not damn it you can do it
it's all about your asset here's the one
thing about me I I tend to shy a little
bit away from when the weight is in the
abdominal region that's okay and that's
just me ii-i'll get more down the trail
that's outstanding
that's outstanding great that's
outstanding because you got a waist you
got that so so more of a shame do you
guys think about like like butt implants
are you guys so not very nosy lien but
not butt implants but when they take the
fat from the stomach on a Brazilian a
lot yeah I've seen it
I might my French girl had its
outstanding Shore and when you go to
Miami yeah all those women have done it
and la I'm about here too I'm a fan oh
you you don't like fake asses and fake
titties no I I'm a big fan of a woman
yeah I mean so yeah I like it all had a
lot yeah yeah no matter what but it's
like I think I want to date my sister
you're the kind of guy I'd want I would
set my girlfriend's up with yeah cuz
most of my friends can't do it you gotta
do it like that
because
my friends my friend is like like you
try my friends bad guys ya know hey soos
a good guy where'd you meet your current
girl that we met in DC DC improv yeah
yeah and yeah like yeah we met a while
ago and you know we kept in contact and
yeah you know what you sound a lot like
Barack Obama he's got the same cadence
his voice yep try to sound like you're
and you rock Obama well yeah I can't see
try to sound like brocco bomb sounds
like to say something that he would say
people people they sound thinking
there's no way you know what I get I get
sometimes with my I get my like throat
raspy it's like I get DMX oh yeah
DMX is that's the one rapper I know a
lot about ya know it's weird but I know
a lot about him he's great I went I love
his music yeah yeah yeah you do sound
like you if I if I raised my voice up
there I could get up there you know my
name is DX D M yeah one of my favorite
rappers but yeah but that's if I get my
voice like I might start to yell it
stays there anyway dark man acts well I
have you been doing in this quarantine
even though it's [ __ ] over you see
zero deaths in New York crying I've been
I've been I've been zero with my folks
oh that's right how's your mom and
everyone doing they're good you know
they're elderly and you know they got
their health issues I've been really
like careful yeah very very careful
but it's good everything's been going
well it just it just new it takes a
little it took a little getting used to
we had a so we have a doctor's
appointment right from my mom and we've
never done one you know over zoom or
Skype so we have a doctor's appointment
my mom sits here I'm there I open the
laptop and we're we're talking the
consultation last like 45 minutes or
whatever and then you know we get done I
close the laptop and won't go and I go
mom so would you think she's like who
was that guy I'm like what do time I was
I was a doctor he's like oh he's I was
wondering like man he knows a lot about
my health so she didn't know who the guy
was she thought we were just talking to
some guy Oh
as you guys set it up yeah we set it up
and I was like it was you know it just
knew it takes a little getting used to
my mom's not told me so it was like I
was like oh man you know Wow yeah so
it's it's been different you know but
what about the protest what your how do
you deal with that it's a I I love that
people are protesting I think it's great
and and and you know to be honest I had
to educate myself a little more I wasn't
well-versed and and you know the the
black lives matter movement you know as
I can in black lives matter and and you
know I'm glad people are out there
protesting and I'm glad people are
donating I'm glad people are signing
petitions and you know mobilizing I
think it's very important you know and
and you know it has to stop and you know
the only way it's gonna stop you know
it's like I've been reading a bunch of
stuff trying to educate you know read
anything I get my hands on it's like and
there's two ways of doing it it's you
know voting you know which which we know
can change things but you know it's that
process is rather slow I mean it's
really slow so it's like it has to be a
mixture like you almost have to hit an
equilibrium point of like mobilizing
protesting because that's how you get
voices heard and you know also voting
and you know it's like doing everything
on every front and you know the more we
learn the better you know we can tackle
this problem so you know over the last
few days I've definitely done a deep
dive and reading as much as I can and
you know I I'm curious to see what the
NFL does because remember when Colin
Kaepernick took a knee how they started
like you know that FL was didn't didn't
really bring any awareness to it they
kind of shunned him he got kicked out of
the league shortly after that and then
anyone else who did then what you can do
be I stay in the yes stay in the locker
rooms so I would imagine now they're
gonna come out and apologize because I
know like the biggest blast Ricky the
biggest black players did a video thing
all saying that you know you kid would
you less protest now but you would we
tried doing it four years ago
try doing silently in peace and you went
let's do it you want us to do it in the
locker I thought the way he what's his
name said we were asking for help we
were asking for Hopkins and that was the
way we had we were asking for help I
guess didn't acknowledge
and it's like it's such a it's such a
tough spot for the NFL though because
Americans are nationalistic and
Americans when you don't stand for the
flag you're you're you have I don't care
what the situation you just have a lot
of Americans that stop listening I've
always said I've always said I've had
these arguments that's tough being being
an American and the flag symbolizes the
the ability you're allowed to do
anything you want including Burnet now I
wouldn't but you're allowed to and
that's to our strengths as a nation the
only thing is the NFL is and you can
speak more to this is a private company
essentially it's a it's a confederation
of companies but you do have to sort of
do what the corporation dictates when
you step into the corporation right
isn't it there's a dress code there's a
there's a protocol there's a way to
behave so that was where it gets tricky
right so this is a for-profit company
they have all your holders they have
their I think that shareholder no sure
okay no sir just for feeling there I'm
sorry yeah and on out of thirty to
twenty nine or white they're okay but
what I'm saying is that a lot of them
are also the baltics of people Americans
watch football all Americans have all
ilk swats football it's such a huge
thing and there are a lot of Americans
that would definitely boycott you it
would not be happy they wouldn't be
happy so it's very very tough for the
owners it really is so I don't know I
don't know this is America this is the
dance we do this is the dance this is
this is the balancing act you're allowed
to be both things you know the other
thing about being American is you can be
you can be pro black lives matter and
then also support police officers you
can do both things but how can you be
pro police officers when you see the the
things that are happening now it's like
it's it's a very touchy go down a tricky
Road yeah it's very if we're all
figuring it out it's like I agree my
father-in-law is a police officer and
when you go on social media and you see
the stuff that's happening because we're
the only post in the bad stuff right but
we see the stuff happen like I think it
was in Buffalo push an old man down his
head started breathing yeah
[ __ ] are you doing they see these out
whether I think it was maybe Seattle
something with her hitting the
protesters they look like you don't so
you have some bad cops and the cops that
are afraid well whatever they're bad or
afraid where the [ __ ] is they're not
qualified do the job you don't have some
of those but the majority cops are good
the majority are good and if you look at
stats actual stats I didn't make this up
this isn't an agenda thing if you look
at stats a lot of it doesn't make sense
what everybody's talking about the
agenda that's can push from the media
right now if you look at the stats it
just it doesn't make sense so it's hard
for me to figure out you mean because
policing has gotten better there's been
progress made way but in that area so so
one of the things that in 2015 over 100
on our and black men were killed by
police office 2000 what 2015 I believe
in 2019 it was nine so so too many but
still progress and I but I think this I
think this these protests are a reaction
to oh I don't know 200 years of of this
so it's not just the last four years no
and then that's why that's so you have
to always remember that this is this is
you have to keep it in context this is
frustration that goes back if you're a
40 year old black man or a 50 year old
black man this is your whole life okay
so to the last four years
policing got better not relevant to when
you're your father had an experience
your grandfather that experience you had
experiences you might know per se it
doesn't so we have to understand that's
why I said me and Brennan were talking
shut the [ __ ] up right now because this
there's a catharsis we need to you know
close our mouths and and and listen with
our ears and open them up and also cops
are all cops aren't the enemy yeah as a
whole the cops it can't be the enemy
you just can't you need to put you're
not you're not pushing the movement when
you go all cops are bad and people are
killing cops not 99 percent of cops are
good but most cops I do the Jonas cops
are appalled by that I all those cops
that did that Instagram thing that they
were talking about how this is [ __ ]
murder and they would they it's terrible
for cops we're friends with with Yosef
azim
who is a buddy of ours who's a cop in
San Francisco it was a great [ __ ] guy
do you know I've seen him police I've
seen his compassion I've seen how he
works with drug addicts and things like
that so we all know that right there
would you're saying perspective we have
to keep all of this in context what I
think is you don't defund reason you
know what what do you think overall and
I know this isn't something we can
figure out it will smoke figure on fire
the kid right now
no actually I think this is gonna be a
very positive step for America why
because because first of all when you
see this many people protest first of
all it isn't just black people there are
a lot of white people Asian people
around the world who are who are going
this can't stand that guy was executed
in daylight in broad daylight by four
pieces of [ __ ] especially that one guy
and we're all outraged by it
everybody's out race but no mate over
here outrage is that because because
here's the thing about that that and we
get these agendas in the the mainstream
media which is public Emily number one
that cop who killed him who had his knee
on his neck was white the other three
officers were not white they're
different no there's one white in the
other three were different ethnicities
yes yes and that's important to keep
into context but more importantly it's a
cop problem yeah no but what I do think
is what I do enjoy is that police
officers the one dangerous police
officers start avoiding dangerous areas
the other like Baltimore I believe by
one stat when there were protests they
started avoiding the hood the bat the
black neighborhoods Baltimore's a very
tough and homicides went up by some
measure 60% you don't want that because
cops get afraid but but I do think the
overall net value of this is no police
officer wants to be have this picture
have his mug shot in a newspaper or on
the internet those are all gonna be very
very careful of that and you if you're
my partner I'm gonna be like bro you're
standing on that guy's [ __ ] neck he
can't breathe oh we've seen this before
stop stop I don't care how mad you are I
don't care what he was saying to you in
the car cuz I believe that guy pulled
him out of the car after they were
having words and he pulled him back out
of the car and to teach him a lesson
hmm you're not gonna see I I believe I
really believe that the net effect of
this when you see this kind of outrage
is that most police officers are gonna
do everything they can to avoid that and
no matter what happens this movement
yours gonna be tops yeah so there's bad
comedians there's bad football players
there's bad producers there's bad
business managers the
you do this is gonna be debated on a
nuanced level right now there's no time
for nuance not right now is no time for
data and stats that's not relevant right
now which isn't which is insane but but
but you can't that's what got us to lock
down with Corona it makes no [ __ ]
sense but you let people go crazy and
then now we're gonna step back as
Americans we're gonna have this talk and
we're gonna have this debate we're gonna
have this we're gonna have this that
we're gonna go too far we're gonna come
back we're gonna go too far the old this
is how it goes in America this is this
is what happens
remember the me to movement it was about
five minutes ago and it went all the way
over for a while and I remember it some
good guys lost a job yeah and now it's
like that was come back in my opinion in
my opinion Hollywood's a better place to
work nice nope so yeah I'm an optimist
maybe I'm I don't know what you know I I
don't have the answers I'm you know I'm
trying to educate myself this
disappoints way bright you know I'm very
dumb you know I think we ought were Alta
and well I learned some of the you know
is like some of the greatest minds have
tried to tackle this problem one way or
another to try to solve it and you know
it's it's a you know like you said it's
an ongoing discussion I hope ok what's
not a problem
is your new special it's me trying to
say grant yeah what's your cause
Malick's stay-at-home son on Showtime
yes watch it for free get with immigrant
parents your parents are from Mexico
really yeah yeah my dad's from Sinaloa
and my mom's from Jalisco and yeah I was
born here Long Beach born and raised
ok yeah this is my first one I was
special man crazy crazy crazy man would
you shoot it up a El Portal ml a writer
in North Hollywood
I'll work did your accent is no joke you
speaking Spanish your first language
yeah it's my first language yeah it's my
first language and I had like full
command of the language up until like
like I didn't have full command of
English
till like around the fifth grade you
know forth and fittest when everything
kind of came together but yeah it's like
how many does that seat mrs. um looks
pretty cool 250
why'd you choose there I'm not a I'm not
a theatre act you know I didn't I didn't
feel confident and going into a bigger
space because I could not feel something
like that
you know
like I'm a comedy club guy kind of thing
and that want to shoot an economy club I
feel like specials are better in clubs I
I think it's great yeah but this one I
think had a had a nice space of like
it's somewhere in between a theater and
a comedy club it's like school it might
be even 300 people but you know after
the cameras and stuff it was less and it
wasn't packed all the way when I shot it
either you know so it's like it's just
reflective of where I am as a comic at
that point in time you know it's like
material attendance you know just you
know it's that's one of the things I
looked at that special like man that's
that's that's interesting especially
it's definitely like a snapshot in time
on a comedian's journey you know it's
like the second special I hope to you
know up my game both as a comic and you
know people showing up and you know all
that stuff but you know it was great it
was it was it was awesome I was involved
with the process every step of the way I
purple curtain have you ever thought
about doing a special in Spanish yeah
I've been actually when I was getting
ready for this special I was already
doing a shows in in Mexico right we're
yeah and I know she's very month away I
wanted a yeah yeah I don't know I just I
never think of there being a stand-up
scene in Mexico there's really no
Netflix special there's there's a bunch
by some really awesome meetings out of
Mexico I got to meet a lot of them
certainly it makes total sense to do
stand-up yes the girls really good and
sure has an entire podcast just in
Spanish like he speaks a Harry Potter
Spanish like a proper like whole [ __ ]
really yeah it's it's like like Harry
Potter but if you spoke Spanish yeah
yeah my god damn yeah yeah it's pretty
good but I sorry I went when I was
getting ready for this there were some
shows that came up and and I went to
Mexico and I ran that hour that I have
now in Spanish and it was like really
cool to kind of instill the hour in my
head because it's like almost like doing
it with my left that's cool yeah well
yeah yeah so what was that like does
that does that it did the jokes hit the
same I ended up like once it was like
fully translated and stuff I lost I
think about between 15 and 20 minutes of
material because of double entendres and
similes and metaphors didn't translate
there was no word for this or no word
for that the wordplay was lost on this
so I had some like original jokes that
you know like observational jokes that I
had just being in Mexico that would make
sense when I think in Spanish if that
makes sense yeah but it was cool and
it's something I'm actively doing I'm I
I definitely you know when I mean why
wouldn't you I I definitely want to do
it and I feel like I could get a like a
second life it's almost like a like a
book you get a second life out of the
same texts you know when yeah you know
the alchemist was don't know open you
know great book that was translated into
many languages and if I could do that
with my hour specials I think I would
have a good good flow like a good work
flow and it also gave me the break after
recording a special do you read a lot
yeah The Alchemist yeah you like that
but I'm not read it it's really good and
now everybody tells me to read it do you
read a lot of fiction I just whatever I
can get my hands on no just like just
hear what the only comedian I know is
that Brennan now it reads but I'm not
kidding I mean nobody I know reads so I
ya know it's great and sometimes I don't
read reads like like read read you know
I was like audiobooks are great you know
yeah great no we drive to a gig or use a
novel sir you um know just like history
stuff I like autobiographies I really
love I love a process I like you know
picking apart somebody's like creative
process who are you sharing yeah who you
hear us Rick Rubin I like Rick Rubin a
lot just because of his critical
thinking mind and how he thinks outside
of the box and you know here you have a
legend who's able to think from every
genre yeah and the hazing babe I try to
go out my beer for a while I'm like I
want to look like him and then I don't
know if that's the look dude no I think
it's really cool he's that guy he's like
Malibu yeah and his studio is in one of
the trailers in his Malibu property but
yeah so is he still involved with
Columbia Records I know yeah he's he's
ahead of he's ahead of Atlantic Records
right or I kind of he's he's a [ __ ]
butt icon the only reason he took the
job was like hey I want the studio and
it's is Johnny Johnny Cash's bus right
the studio's Bill
on on that property and Malibu but look
here's what's great about Rick Rubin not
only has he transcended music from every
genre or the country to rap to you know
like he's also dabbled in comedy he
produced one of Andrew Dice clays
release albums see like he's a guy whose
big picture you know he you know yeah
look at his work but he brings down
petty Justin Timberlake Metallica Slayer
many famous musicians I mean Rage
Against the Machine Red Hot Chili
Peppers - Kendrick Lamar yes so it's
like - Red Hot Chili Peppers - being in
the studio with jay-z and and him
setting aside his you know his biases
and whatever the preference of music
that he has but be objective and have
hit records that's very hard to do yeah
he's kind of Zen right he studies yeah
he meditates right a bit I I think he's
he's vegan he drinks like I saw this
thing on on YouTube this is all aren't
stuff that I've seen on YouTube he like
meditates and drinks bunch of these
green juices and it's like such a
beautiful way to live I think it's very
impressive I I I definitely would love
to work on a project with this guy I one
day like at some point just because of
you know how was your experience with
the complex and the talk was going okay
so voice that goes contou [ __ ] yeah yeah
that goes contou low was great I mean
those you know complexes you know good
people over there first we feast just
phenomenal good people over there man
and yeah we vibed out I went down there
to New York I went in there for what was
supposed to be a quick meeting in two
hours later I'll walk out and we're like
best friends we're hugging and cool and
then you know they had this project that
they wanted me to host you know and
they're just like you just host it
usually we work with people that are
cooking stuff is they just host she's
like doing it it was great it was it was
a different muscle I don't think I had
the hosting training or background you
know it also squared you got almost like
you gotta listen be affected like you
got it Josh wolf is a very good host
like though you got to be like a spot
there's just there's different thing to
it you got to be interested in whatever
the [ __ ] is going on funny even if it's
bull ring let's
but at least what dish you got to work
with a lot of your fans yeah no it was
great it was it was it was yeah really
good it was fun we ate a lot of food
anyway
what give us a book you recommend I
think you cleared your throat there hmm
it was three books David please don't
give us three months I'll just give you
really yeah one one really good one
David Lynch those five books huh Lynch
finding the big fish or yeah David Lynch
he's a big film director David Lynch the
film director yeah yeah yeah he's a
really intense and gentle meditation
catching the big fish meditation
consciousness and he'd never seen his
movies he's such a wild [ __ ]
he's a wild man and in this book he he
talks about you know and I think it
relates to to comment I was kind of read
stuff and I related to comedies and he
had this chapter in there to two
chapters that really stuck out at me
it's like when you know as a creative
when you shed the the clown suit he's
like you know we wear this clown suit
and it's a rubber thing and inside
there's a rancid smell you know but with
time you kind of shed this clown suit to
kind of get to the truth of whatever is
an underlying but it doesn't the clown
sir doesn't really go away right away
because you still have to the the the
smell that goes along with it so
eventually you not only do you shed the
the suit you also said the the smell
that goes with it but he had this
chapter that I thought was really great
he said that he was filming a movie and
one of the people behind the camera was
like smoking a cigarette and looking
himself in the mirror and that uh there
they broke down to shoot another shot
right and he told me one to stay put and
told the guy don't move and they shot
the scene he's like I did not use it for
that movie I did not know why I needed
it but I knew I needed it so he held on
to it now for remember crazy shot the
guy behind the camera looking in the
mirror it was just like a gaffer smoking
a cigarette was I stay there they shot
it didn't use it until he ended up using
that in another project yeah on the line
if I remember correctly but for like
comics it's like you know that
that feeling where you're like well I
gotta write that yeah yeah I mean I use
it right I guess this hour and I thought
it was like so brilliant but anyway
that's awesome let's do some current
events that's current events Brennan
it's about total human optimization oh
my god about about on it one of our most
loyal sponsors for how many years now if
I have 14 years Jenny for Tokyo brain
food you in one mood sleep you want
digestive hell you want support and
vitality essential nutrients performance
you on the immune system you want gold
based collections like Kido collection
yeah building blocks a muscle sure who
wouldn't sleep dude they got you when it
comes to your health while you're
performing boys when I when I wake up in
the morning I
I grind up I put in some [ __ ] yeah
coffee it's a black rifle and on it they
have extra caffeinated crystals in it it
will get your reven so we can pump out
some miles right so I do every goddamn
morning yeah if it's black rifle on it
your tempers off go to on it calm slash
fighter for 10% off [ __ ] yeah coffee
they have regular dark roast coffee they
have protein so you got joint little fat
butter they got it all warrior bars keto
hot sauce everything on it calm slash
fighter tempers on hold damn sight
you're welcome you're welcome hey kids
Brian passed away I'm about to
sorry something my throat I'm so excited
for you see 250 this weekend Brian
passed away so he's not here he's
getting his lids done or I don't know
listen this Saturday UFC 250 is kicking
off June and make money while watching
the fights man you know the fights you
like money now's your chance to win a
shot at $1,000,000 top prizes all right
if you haven't tried it yet fancy MMA is
so dang easy just pick six fighters stay
in the salary cap
pile up the points where advances
takedowns and more there's no better way
to put your MMA knowledge to the test
than to compete at 1 million dollars
because nothing makes a UFC event more
exciting than when you have skin in the
game with draftkings
for a limited time draftkings is
offering both new and existing users
deposit bonus up to $500 downloads
draftkings app now and use the promo
code fighter to get free shot at 1
million dollars
alright your first deposit that's promo
code fighter to get a free shot
1 million dollars with your first
deposit only at draftkings minimum final
deposit required deposit bonus requires
25 time playthrough eligibility
restrictions apply see draft kings.com
for details again that's download
draftkings promo codes fighter to get a
free shot at $1,000,000 her and Brendan
Fox his nicotine brandon has a substance
abuse problem I don't know I don't know
you use on the yeah yeah okay so Jake
Paul has been formally charged with
unlawful assembly and criminal
trespassing this past weekend he was
actually in Scottsdale Arizona where
people have footage of him at a mall at
a local mall while they're looting and
it seems like he's just kind of walking
around vlogging it and people called him
out for it he shortly after went onto
Instagram and released a statement
saying that he was out protesting all
day and what he ended up doing was
getting caught in some sort of situation
where he got tear-gassed he had to go
then walk back to wherever he was
staying and somehow are you in the mall
looting you he says he wasn't he was
trying to go you'd basically trying to
vlog that's fair the protests yeah you
people have me sticking up from I don't
I've never met Jake I know Logan I know
Logan well Logan's my buddy I don't know
his brother this guy does a lot of
stupid [ __ ] nobody Jake Paul it's so
people are looting and you're you're
documenting it like a journalist would
which is what journalists do no
journalists are sticking up or play the
video chin oh she's not journalists No
that's him God oh he's he's he's doing
this for his YouTube channel and just
commenting on he meets like she's in the
mall right now logs yeah there they go
he's kind of being like oh [ __ ] him and
then this is in the mall right yeah
behavior its criminal behavior where the
cops
this is Arizona yep Scottsdale look at
[ __ ] strength property and stealing a
bull well we don't see him doing him no
he doesn't do hold on did he just say
get me a free clone no this is somebody
else who was at the mall looting and
they actually saw him and notice him
they thought he was his brother Logan at
first and so they're just kind of
walking around following him and that's
what this woody he's not a looter but
he's definitely not you know people
don't like that he's going out of his
way to be in situations like this to
monetize off of it later on YouTube
oh he's monetizing good oh yeah because
he's known for it's a profiteer on
destruction of property yes what do you
guys think cuz but this gives him this
gives him content cuz he was I get
tear-gassed we went to the mall with
looters and they're gonna get
tear-gassed so it's like a whole
narrative form so it's like he's
capitalizing on the movement and
everything going on to be absolutely
clear neither I nor anyone in our group
was engaged in looting or vandalism for
context spent the day during our part to
peacefully protest one of the most
horrific in Jessica all right but the us
being tear gas for for filming the
events and brutality that were unfolding
in Arizona where gas and forced to keep
moving on foot we film everything I mean
I I have to say that he was documenting
it I don't know what he did that was a
crime or that was no crime no it's a
it's a crime no but but I also don't
know
criminal charges yeah because no one was
supposed to be inside the mall and wait
he's getting kernel charge because he's
famous they know where he is what about
everybody else I think well it's hard to
identify everyone else who was in the
video he's just officious a big name
yeah yeah I don't I don't know I'm not
so sure
if people are in there and you're
[ __ ] filming it and you're
documenting something
i-isn't that what I I don't know if
that's a crime I don't know if I'm mad
at him no it's not a crime I don't know
I don't know if I'm even mad at that
documenting is not a crime right but but
being in there yeah yes if I go in there
with my camera to capture this moment in
history these [ __ ] these [ __ ]
criminals and [ __ ] who are stealing
and not protesting they're stealing now
you know you got everybody in there
being like they're having a good old
time I'm sorry but they are and they're
breaking stuff and private property and
he's got a camera filming it where do we
put that in the context I don't know say
you're part of the problem if you're
younger if you're a young man
yeah if you're a young man and you go in
there with looters yeah and film it to
upload to your YouTube page make money
off of your partner making money off it
that's a problem he's definitely making
money on go to Brian that's the only
reason why he filming okay he's not
filming it create change right he's film
it to me was not being placed he's not
filming it gives him content for his
page it's similar to the talk okay what
have you standing on the street in you
do and you're documenting it right and
somebody's breaking the windows will
cross it along the street and you're
filming it and you put on your YouTube
no you talk about a pristine hon he went
into the mall with the looters like damn
oh my god there he's still breaking [ __ ]
and filming it so let's say we so we go
to Arizona next week yeah and they start
breaking in I go hey B I'm gonna get
footage for a final kid YouTube paid
yeah I'm gonna go in there with them and
film it you like what the [ __ ] you and I
can like yeah no no I just want to see
it dude yeah you think what are you
doing yeah don't be a [ __ ] it's
definitely it's definitely help sitting
and you're not helping with anything
you're monetizing off looting I'm
personally I'm still I'm not mad at them
oh yeah still person I'm still just way
bigger ish
yeah
if he would have thrown a break or
something then we should be man exactly
there's way big issue he walked through
a law and had a video camera I'm not so
sure I'm I'm way mime way more angry at
the people smashing windows and stealing
my anger I don't have any I don't have I
don't have any other my I have a lot of
anger for him that means I have a lot of
anger for the other people I can see I
can see anger for kids going into
Patagonia and [ __ ] stealing
everything mountain bikes for our eyes
see here's the prompt
I repeat [ __ ] Jake Paul he's a Miller
looting while people outside protesting
wasn't then that's just what someone's
saying that's the problem that's the
problem is people he's looting this and
the media and then social media is on
there but that's not the truth yeah yeah
it's not the truth at all yeah well he
does have a huge reach too right so what
if he did want to do something like show
the world what people are doing that's
true now that's fair - that's I haven't
seen that I've never seen a show
does he like show this and like this is
[ __ ] up we're trying to do this do we
know we might be showing it well you
don't know what he intended to do with
this particular footage but he does make
shock value content for kids so it's
like his whole demographic is I think
within the ages of like 12 to like even
like very very young yeah yeah my
daughter she's 12 what was yeah it's
like what was this intense yeah you want
to do with that footage let's see - yeah
- play devil's advocate with you can't
but it's like you know yes so how many
millions of followers and maybe it's
like hey this what's going on kids like
check this out man this is what we're
dealing with
yeah that's why I'm like you're going
through with a camera and your doctors
defusing I for me when I see that that
it makes me mad and it makes me realize
that there's a lot of shitty stuff that
that has you're not helping the
protestor at the moment you're just
being [ __ ] we filmed everything we
saw an effort to share experience and
bring more attention that anger felt and
they were hood we were travel through
all right maybe all right I'll never
really know I have our best to raise
awareness I don't know man I have I
don't have the energy to criticize him I
have I have problems with there are a
lot of other people have problems with
let's put it that way I don't have room
I don't have room there are things Mars
is the narrative from the media things
karate correct or the people yeah I just
ran into something yeah all right okay
so this past week a lot of people have
been talking about fans of kpop because
on May 30th the Dallas Police Station
released a tweet saying that they
created an app where they want you to
upload footage of people protesting
people looting and people rioting so
they can try to figure out who these
people are who are like breaking curfew
just being out and about and what ended
up happening was a bunch of people
within the kpop community found out that
they were trying to get people to snitch
on protesters so they went out of their
way to go on to the app and crash it by
uploading photos of k-pop stars
performing and and saying we're not
gonna snitch on people and so the whole
site actually ended up crashing within
24 hours
Wow damn and a couple days later
something similar happened where the
hashtag black lives matter was trending
on Twitter
and people try to get the hashtag white
lives matter to trend on Twitter as well
they also took over that hashtag and
started uploading a bunch of k-pops
like people taking [ __ ] over just stuff
putting up different like clips of kpop
stars performing saying what these have
a message yeah apparently a lot of the
auntie ffice stuff is is is also hackers
just [ __ ] we're coming in the loo
your neighborhood and a lot of this
they're finding is just a bunch of
hackers [ __ ] around like just you
know lot of it's really Antipa though a
lot of it's also hackers a lot of a lot
of this stuff is like yeah you know
although yes there's also different guys
doing this yeah yeah don't give them too
much good you know but but you know is
that a guy oh yes okay plastic surgery
is it straight up Korean people doing it
or is no k-pop fans are international
everywhere yeah literally everywhere I
think me pop bands are the scariest like
group of fans and I don't like you're a
bunch of k-pop stars commit suicide cuz
these same fans that hate on yes but
also it's like if you thought
fanbases who followed like one direction
or NSYNC our Backstreet Boys are badass
kpop is so much crazier and their
international like people literally when
BTS performs it's nuts
yes Korea I believe has the highest
suicide rate per capita so too
was is there is there a one group in
particular is there BTS is probably the
biggest one but people who follow kpop
in general are so diehard for some
reason like nobody really understands
why but people within the k-pop
community are incredibly huge in China
could it be never could it be like the
message that they're saying is there is
their music with a certain message I'm
not it's just I don't know it's super
positive and it's super catchy and it's
very sad awesome like it's candy you
don't even know you watch it and you'll
just enjoy your gang girl I mean the
main kpop that's not cable that's right
it's still considered a new cassette
yeah okay phases the most watchable is
it in the earlier phases no it's just a
different like genre even though it's
the same genre but it's different
category and you know what stands mean
now stands so Korean fans they use that
to the word stand from the Eminem song
stands like that obsessive
so when you love your kpop artist that
much your standard venom oh that's oh
nice transcending hip-hop it's so it's
everywhere Latin America Latin America
is enormous
yeah the fan base for cute Korean pop is
literally that was South Korea's plan
yessuh what the United States is Europe
when it comes to pop culture Philly did
they kill TV music incredible incredible
remember the the company I worked for it
was the largest Korean television
network in the world no matter what
happened to them if the ratings are bad
or whatever they still continue to fund
it because it was funded by the Korean
government right to influence the work
huge
move there it was a joint effort and
they did it pull it off in ten years
Korea when they mobilize they work
together and all those kpop band members
they're crying on the inside they're
gonna put on a hell of a show they're
overworked like what is watch this guy
try to recreate good let's watch this
you guys remember this commercial right
that's great
kendall Jenner walking up use acaba yeah
a Pepsi in it resolves everything yeah
he looks he's not a candidate there's
something about Kendall Jenner that she
does it a little better I don't know if
would have done so yeah a lot of people
have been bringing Pepsi's out to
protests right now ninja cops I love
America I love my country I love it all
trust me we all try all right next one
Lucky's Chuckie Cheese trending what
another shooting there does your
favorite fast food chain mattress date I
keep going this is interesting the
GoFundMe campaign for George Floyd it is
the most ever donated by individuals so
the account of people that actually
donating it's the most inhibit in
history of GoFundMe thirteen million
don't know five hundred thousand almost
five hundred thousand individual people
have donated to the campaign family get
that 13 million dollars yeah whoever
started the campaign I sure said sure
it's for his family there's [ __ ]
shady ones yes of our course no they
fired a bunch of them that people
started but an interesting thing about
this is the number two on go farming
donations is the money to build a wall
at America's southern border that has
300,000 donations 25 million dollars to
build the wall that's what more money
I'm trying to start going from me for
Jon Jones France than gone oh I mean but
you gotta hit 10 mil that's all in third
place
intensive care beds and pandemic ravaged
Italy
206 yeah 26 damn bad bad bad but baby at
the rehab rehab for what for childhood
trauma and also prescription pills she's
like 17 17 but I mean imagine what she's
going through a lot with reality stars
to where they don't know that they're
gonna be so famous overnight that they
don't know how to deal with that instant
fame so they're trying to numb it she
kept yeah really really really fast like
overnight when she went on dr. Phil
mm-hmm and she was painted as the
villain too so that doesn't really help
anything I got a lot of hate imagine the
world hating you're at 13 just overnight
be tough
that's not that'd be really good yeah
it's [ __ ] really are I don't think
people are meant to be famous I agree
especially now it's so shabby like
there's like you know like Tom Cruise
famous is it was it the plan we're not
done our DNA to deal with that I like a
thing about George I don't know why I'm
not George Cleon my bike ride this
morning well that's what I'm saying like
I seen it George kun-hee cuz I have some
stuff going on and so in reference
George Clooney and I was thinking of
them and like he's not social media he
moved to Italy he doesn't deal with any
anything I'm he's so famous but he can't
go anywhere no can't you can't do
anything humans aren't weren't meant to
be this not in depth on that height of
his fame moved to a small town in
southern France I would [ __ ] solve
that she'll DiCaprio man it's like you
can't know who wants to be a [ __ ] la
father think we'll think well you can't
go anywhere like that like if you want
to get coffee you shut down the coffee
store you stopped to get gas with people
you know what I deal with on a daily
basis nah why me my [ __ ] me where's
my March no I found your demo is when we
went to Vegas do a show together and the
drivers doing 40 hell up to me and then
these old like oh my gold Birds Brandon
just next card of a ladies built like
girls that hey Zeus lights would come up
to
Mellor hey roses just taking these what
else you got alright this is a pretty
crazy one this LA Galaxy Player oh my
god what were they thinking what do you
mean go ahead the wife the wife posted
something on social media which is
horrific so she wrote in Serbian to kill
those protesting again of killed those
protesting against the systemic racism
and police brutality in the wake of
George Floyd's death and she also wrote
just gusting cattle yes should fill
these disgusting cattle okay well you
got your man fired you dumb did she yes
oh yeah he had to have a talk cuz he
completely disagrees with her for
obvious reasons but then the galaxy did
parts ended up parting ways with him the
galaxy like you know we can't have this
damn and he actually took a stand
against her posts that's what you said
here I don't know what's wrong with her
though why would you do it just be crazy
bro Serbian sometimes you come from
Serbia they came from the Serbs and the
cross and the Bosnia and Herzegovina ins
today they are they all had they all had
fights you know there was a ethnic there
was ethnic tension but I mean him
getting fired I don't know how they
ended up working out him getting fired I
think it's a bomber they fired him this
is where I have a problem with
especially he's against wife said
something you fire this [ __ ] guy and
he apologized the LA Galaxy were made
aware of this and violent social media
posts by his with the wife
I really just commend the social posts
required immediate removal but I think
it's what's that have to do with him I
agree and then this is says mutually
agreed to part ways which I got was a
she got a big severance pay I hope no no
it doesn't work like that no no I think
I've been fighting that's post I would
think you don't I don't fly don't fire
the man for for what his dumb wife's
head but his contract could have been up
to and they're trying to negotiate but
that was no severance pay but either way
that sucks but what do you do if you're
that guy when you just have to just get
a divorce at that point oh no I think
she's from Serbia so she but also how
long they've been together horribly
I don't know she's so hot I'll put up
with some [ __ ] a lot of guys would yeah
I don't know I mean let's not tell you
right now if my wife posted something
that was racist there's a good chance
that I probably believe the same thing
she's not gonna post something that
we're all not you know I'm saying well I
disagree I just mean if she's dropping
you don't agree with everything your
wife says in fact you when it comes to
that that's pretty also you're saying
that he probably is complicit in her but
she's defending himself I think you I
think it's possible to [ __ ] be with
somebody may erase us who's a good
person and then they say some [ __ ] and
you're like what hold on hold on huh
shit's different Welsh's we should kill
these vile pigs or rot that cat rod for
pigs cattle that's like that's not terms
like if she messed up like like it drew
brees did where you can't disrespect hey
listen III don't you just kill these in
town I'm gonna say like let if we're
friends I would never be your friend if
I'm or first time hanging out and we're
watching news like that they should
[ __ ] yeah I just I agree I agree
you're you're probably right I don't
think you fire somebody for what
somebody else no maybe I don't think ice
my off - sniffing I don't disagree with
you like I I would I would probably say
I'm racist and if I'm racist your or
nine times out of 10 I'd say what the
your shirt yes but sometimes you have
friends who are married to a [ __ ]
there you we all know guys who are great
guys and they're married to a [ __ ]
nightmare cut yeah but get your laces
yeah they can be no hello any my parents
are friends with a [ __ ] I don't know
if she's a racist but they're they're
friends with somebody who is the
greatest guy no he's married to the
biggest piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
she sucks and they've been married
forever but she's a bad person and it's
like and we're all like what is he doing
yeah we've all seen that different than
then by the way that guy didn't get
fired because his wife is a piece of
[ __ ] somebody shouldn't lose his job
yeah that's aren't but it's all just
it's a very slippery household you know
I'm saying like if my girl is an N ba
bad but what yeah let's put this way
yeah if we're at dinner and and
somebody's wife says some [ __ ] you'd be
like I don't like those guys like
neither wise
with her get up and walk I'm gonna get
up and walk uh leave the table I don't
make fun of them yeah nobody what are
you doing dude yeah I mean it's it's not
good yeah it's not good yeah but yeah
this room here has a firing um man for
what his wife says isn't very very
dangerous
I'm sure I'm curious if maybe his
contract was up with the guy still
trying to figure out and then this came
out there like I dude we don't want to
do this you don't that's a good credit
greedy guard yeah I didn't look too much
into the actual soccer player but I
don't know feels like I'm just walk on
guy or so like a huge star I don't know
so we'll have a ton of fun hey guys just
give me a second I left you called I
wanted to make sure it's a he's okay
sure all right back in um this I just
saw recently right now family silver got
hit by a car in Brazil and apparently
this is the second time this has
happened when he's riding his bike dude
a motorcycle
I didn't bicycle and he said wearing a
helmet is what helped to say buzzer and
I've hit my head where if I don't have
helmet on like really we felt were CT
for be shop here yeah I've been bad oh
man thank God I bet helmet on think
gotta fly racing specialize damn with
your old biking legend to traffic lights
if it's traffic lights it could be a
motorcycle right this is bike thrown
from his bike
I would assume he rides a bike in
Curitiba so I've been there right I
fought down it's insane the bikes going
through the I mean how that I'm sure
there's a consol the time yeah it's
pac-man traffic and they're going
through and it's nuts
so Jase it's pretty bad that's bad yeah
he's his face has taken a lot of his
body he does I saw the first thing I
thought oh he's been or look like yeah
metal inside his cheese if you get that
Tyson fight after this oh yeah oh damn
this is not that new this mid-may and
it's about this girl who was babysitting
a kid who's 13 years old and she was 20
years old and then she ended up coming
home one day over to the house one day a
little bit buzz after going out and then
she saw him playing Nintendo or whatever
and then she started seducing him and
then they had sex multiple times but
hold on how
as a kid 13 how old is she 20 this is 20
17 she was also married at the time too
to another young guy look at the details
here and it looks got some reduce to
Tina Chester need after going into his
bedroom where you spend Xbox following a
drunken night out she hugged and kissed
him before ponens travels begging him
for sex Cordy scored East cordis yeah
Courtney conceded to have sex with him
which she kept hidden from her husband
till she gave birth to a baby girl yeah
Bart jurors heard how she had groom the
boy by cinema company tech con him cute
and giving him money for fish and chips
anyhow she's sentenced to 30 months is
the baby is the bait that baby had to be
given up and in for adoption oh the baby
was the 13 year olds yeah huh yep not
the husband not the husband she got
pregnant my 30s yeah and then now the
kid is also he said he said separation
anxiety suffering from that because he
can't see his kid you know cuz they had
to give away yeah 13:02 13 year old
who's now in that situation oliveira
yeah i mean that's and that was her
husband how old are they they're young
or tween and another thing they found
out they did psychiatric tests and they
fired her IQ was that like she was it um
70 to 85 she's she's miss for scope yeah
she's Forrest Gump there's a lot of
there's a lot of problems before skill a
lot of things are going on man I'm still
blown away that though he 35 got a 20
year old again he'd rather be the father
of the kids and he's the flaw makes
sense so the father is 13 year old kid
huh that's right it's a bummer and
that's weird crazy
I don't know so they did that test right
to see if it's a match if it's his baby
is if it was 14 million times likely
that it's his kid 30 year old yeah just
say yeah yeah that's more than a hundred
percent isn't it well there's a it's 14
million there's a 14 million times
chance that's now like that could have
stopped 14 million well it's like oh
just say $100 just say
they're 1 out of 14 million it's highly
likely harder well how likely it 14
million likely 14 your looks weird is no
one really gives a [ __ ] about stats like
that no one wants to hear the stats yeah
do you know if you're under 26 these are
and these are fact there's no debate
you're more likely to get hit by
lightning and you already died from
Corona suck on that
that's right Brendan [ __ ] you ask and
where's that [ __ ] outbreak how the
hospital is doing so my god [ __ ] but
the lake of those are throwing masks on
there's your car there was zero death
and poverty zero zero like you say love
it get that [ __ ] at ease
thirteen-year-old impregnated a 20 year
old fine kid next to someone did get it
though does this help us here yes fine
before you went out there positive one
guess somebody got it oh okay um this is
just I guess a little funny video not a
funny subject like I saw any video yeah
okay so this woman's getting detained by
the police not so distracting what so
she starts singing throw that disgusting
you know
yo Chuck you ain't even got no job cuz
he's laughing
leave him laughing that's funny zero
there's a cop all that he's what
happened oh she's hilarious
so there's someone did a remix of it the
roommates pretty hard at underscore
random of just offset to put a beat to
this underscore random J in school yes
turn away cuz he's laughing it's
probably the highlight of his week
that's pretty much it so it's [ __ ]
hilarious
I like that some reason you about lose
your job the remake this is another
video song parcel someone jumping out of
a window
I love into the pool alright they wind
this Oh God
indoor pool you know what though he
landed with his hands I know I get thank
God because I was hot like blown just he
could have gone he got burned in half
you gonna got show
[Applause]
that's actually really good considering
how bad it cut them in half oh yeah
you about to get cut in half I won't
point that that guy was like you know
what I think I could pull this off I
know maybe he's drinking it's a small
pool course for Dean oh man you scared
us ever been my life jumping from cliff
diving in in Missouri Lake of the Ozarks
all right I'm sorry Table Rock right
next to Ozarks he almost ate it jumping
out of the little dude it's so scary
I don't get how people do it I would
never do it in my clothes to the to the
top of that window look I'm not a big
fan oh the topping me yeah yeah you're
right his head I don't like cliff diving
I can't no no that's good good for him
my friend is gonna loose officer and a
man tried to jump you tell me these
pictures a man jumped out the window
away from them he had raped somebody
okay they were chasing him and he jumped
out the window and he it was a
three-story window and he hit another
fence and his head came off clean his
head just sat on the fence justice it
just went boom and his body was there
and I was like that's the [ __ ] you see
like Mortal Kombat oh yeah I was like
his head but his head was horribly
popped off yeah it was crazy over his
hat stayed on meaning yes I swear to God
I was like oh [ __ ] do not during the
protests you know when there's looters
and stuff I guess these guys wanna rob I
forget what but they stole cars see how
the news is it just follows it I
couldn't get enough of it but cop chases
them chasing then they get on foot I'm
like [ __ ] yeah just got good and the
dudes are running and you know what
[ __ ] them they're cardio because
they're running and the cops are running
you can tell the cop slowing down and
then they really slowed down and another
cop comes out you see this female cop
come out of nowhere and Bobby Boucher is
that oh [ __ ] oh it's fantastic must-see
TV
that's impressive that's good but cardio
if these looters should learn one thing
it's you gotta step your cardio up cuz
you run from these cops you could get
away but they get tired i watch the
stripper of this streaker
Oster
football a game and and and if this when
he realized that he was like this small
white guys [ __ ] boom there's like man
right and you see these two Samoan dudes
built about size security guards and
they were but what that kid didn't
realize there Simone's there fast is
[ __ ] whatever it was he's like to troll
like geologists are like HIPAA right
well like like oak trees running super
fast at us they caught that [ __ ]
oh yeah
tackle him super heroes those streakers
get lit the [ __ ] oh yeah and then Jewish
securities living for this that they're
like oh hell yeah we got some action
here yeah it's a run on the field and do
it and I was watching now's your time
stop seven on really fan takedowns
please click on that video
let's see NFL Savage exams have you
they're not that nice they're kind of
accident this is where they get [ __ ]
up though this guys are come on you want
some security oh this is just on Oh what
do they get taken out there Christic is
this Christian Stephanie I don't know
this doesn't look good though no this
looks awful what you want to watch Brian
okay this is me that you seen that video
where there's a arrest that gets like a
flashback that he played football so
they snapped the ball and he goes and he
tackles somebody no way bro high school
to video a ref tackles football player
and it's like they snap man yes yeah et
never know what's gonna pop up rear its
ugly head any of these you said to high
school no no not high school this is
like pro
weird some years ago referee tackling
football players I try that one yeah
this is oh god I miss college football
I can't wait for this to pop up how
about NBA announced they're coming back
really first yeah it's a 22 team playoff
system they're basically just want sign
in the playoffs whatever I don't care so
they have sign Williams in the playoffs
now definitely gonna win it but he's in
there so we're excited and they're how
stupid how this how stupid this is I'm
fired up a little whiskey listen this
Knicks demon how about how about this
Brian Cowen the NBA is gonna have a 22
team season and the playoffs to me
seven-game series which I love but
they're gonna keep them quarantined at
Walt Disney World at the where they were
there all those things you're gonna love
this but the parks gonna be open so the
team just acorn so sweet fans these
people are you can ride Magic Mountain
oh my god go to Legoland yeah you can go
to the alligator [ __ ] all right I
didn't turn out to be what it was how
many times have we lost ours it's ours
it's Sudama but how about the teams they
have to be Cortland this is his car see
can't see anybody yeah get it together
everybody thanks Brian
sure buddy in that crazy so there's a
long I'll be I'll be at Disney World
I'll be in that cop playing grab-ass and
then the teams have stay quarantined in
there and play each other with no fans
excuse thank you for coming by yeah
thank you for having me you're the best
yeah we love you man Jones all right
Showtime on Showtime check it out thank
you guys for having me yeah are we sold
out in Phoenix
we're sold out we're sorry again but you
know what we are sorry but Phoenix is
open up more cuz they're allowing 50%
capacity with fans as far as stadiums go
so they think by Monday they're gonna
release more tickets for show that's
beautiful all shows are sold out so keep
jumping on Monday because they should
release more San Antonio lol I'll be
there June 25 26 27 those tickets go
let's go
so that's became yet Spokane's sold out
the thick boy by club meeting is
Saturday the 27th sign up at Thicke boy
ride at gmail.com
Salt Lake City wise guys July 16th
through the 18th the 18th we'll do our
ride
also sign up a thick boy ride at
gmail.com and yeah man get your thick
boy gear right now we got new [ __ ]
dropping men and women's gear coming
soon sick boy calm dude we love you hey
suit you're on Showtime right now do you
have a promo code so if they'll announce
Showtime they can yeah your days free
you can just go on the website try it
for 30 days and if you like it stick
with it if now you can cancel it at any
time boom go watch it now he's with nice
guys in the biz also when the funniest
I love hey soos treho all right man this
fine kid we're out